oh mais que se passe-t-il qu'est-ce qui
va annoncer est-ce qu'il est papa il a
décidé de se mettre à la cuisine et ce
qu'il arrête YouTube du Kamel excuse je
sais que vous avez peur quand j'annonce
un truc mais là c'est que du bonus c'est
que du kif déjà j'ai vu ce tweet et puis
quoi encore vous croyez qu'il serait
d'horreur c'est un film Le Seigneur des
Anneaux trois heures pour qui vous
prenez les 12000 TRT ça là eh
redescendez ok il y a un lien entre ce
tweet et ce que je vais vous annoncer
dans un instant mais sachez que non ce
n'est pas un trait d'horreur qui sort le
jour d'Halloween c'est un nouveau
concept une vidéo beaucoup plus longue
qu'un trait d'horreur qui je pense va
vous plaire et qui évidemment fait
frissonner en revanche j'entends vos
demandes vos cris de désespoir au sujet
des extrait d'horreur il y aura donc
dans quelques jours un skateboard qui
sortira le stress d'horreur du mois
d'octobre et pour fêter la sortie de ce
que je vais annoncer dans cette vidéo il
y aura cinq histoires au lieu de 3 et
durant un peu plus de 20 minutes ce sera
l'équivalent du trait d'horreur qu'on
avait fait pour Halloween l'année
dernière finalement bref passons au
projet oh je suis ému ça fait un truc à
chaque fois d'annoncer les gros projet
là vous le savez je suis fan de
l'horreur ça fait des années des années
que je joue à des jeux d'horreur sur
Youtube et maintenant sur twitch et ça
fait un moment qu'on fait des trait
d'horreur ça fait longtemps que je bosse
là dessus parce que je voulais vraiment
que le résultat soit à la hauteur de mes
exigences et de mes espérances je suis
fier aujourd'hui de vous annoncer que
c'est le lancement des précommandes
d'une BD inspirée des vidéos serait
d'horreur avant de vous en parler plus
en détail je vous ai concocté un petit
teaser pour vous mettre dans l'ambiance
petites heures à la fin duquel vous
découvrirez le nom de la BD et soyez
attentifs parce qu'il y a énormément
d'indices sur les histoires de la BD
[Musique]
et il donne envie de teaser je l'adore
Blic c'est le nom de la BD oh ça me fait
quelque chose enfin vous la présentez
j'ai en ma possession le tout premier
prototype de la BD c'est à dire que
dedans là
il y a même pas les pages imprimées
encore en revanche il y a le bon nombre
de pages à 80 pages c'est les bonnes
dimensions de couverture c'est un peu
plus grand et large qu'une BD classique
et surtout il y a la couverture que je
trouve vraiment belle et c'est même pas
la couverture définitive puisque là elle
est en papier glacé en version maths ça
donne ça je vous parle dans un instant
de pourquoi il y en a une rouge pour
qu'on ait une bleu mais celle-ci je dois
dire que on aurait pas pu faire mieux
vous y retrouverez trois histoires
d'horreur originales écrites par
Lorraine moi-même et Guillaume nathas on
a fait ça entre amis on s'est régalé on
s'est pris la tête aussi beaucoup alors
pourquoi une BD pas un roman frérot je
suis pas écrivain ça va me prendre au
moins cinq ans d'écrire un roman vous le
savez quand je serai un truc j'ai
beaucoup bossé dessus donc évidemment
j'en suis très fier là que ce soit la
couverture les histoires les dessins et
d'ailleurs en parlant des dessins il y a
trois dessinateurs qui ont travaillé sur
la BD puisqu'ils ont chacun illustré une
histoire en plus d'être une histoire
différente à chaque fois bah il y a une
ambiance différente vu que c'est pas le
même dessinateur merci Diane merci
Frédéric et merci Julien pour votre
travail vous avez été monstrueux et
aussi à Camille pour le storyboard qui a
fait un travail incroyable je suis très
content parce que déjà c'est le premier
truc qu'on sort autour du de l'horreur à
part les frais d'horreur donc forcément
ça me fait quelque chose et puis surtout
là on est en train de créer un terrain
de jeu parce que Blic ce ne sera pas que
des BD il y aura trois BD mais ça va
être aussi d'autres trucs comme par
exemple évidemment ça fait longtemps que
j'en parle des courts-métrages vous le
savez on en a même regardé plusieurs
fois en live il y a plein de courts
métrages d'horreur sur Youtube dont
certains donnaient naissance à des films
et j'ai pas mal d'idées de comment
mettre à jour que j'aimerais faire il
s'inscriront dans cet univers Blic tout
comme par exemple les films conjuring
s'inscrivent dans l'univers conjuring
que ce soit Annabelle la nonne les
dossiers de Warren tout ça pour le
moment la BD n'est pas disponible dans
le commerce elle est disponible
uniquement en précommande sur Blic
project.com pourquoi on a fait des
précommandes contrairement à olives
qu'on avait fait à l'époque avec Maxence
et mon frère qui s'appelait tourne la
page parce que ça laisse place à des
éditions limitées et un peu collector et
à des trucs RP et ça ça me fait kiffer
je voulais pas juste proposer une BD je
voulais aussi proposer différentes
options et donner un avantage à ceux qui
soutiennent les projets à leur genèse et
vous êtes très nombreux à chaque fois à
soutenir mes projets très vite à leur
jeunesse donc les précommandes pour moi
c'était l'occasion justement de régaler
ces gens là quels sont donc les
avantages de la précommande excellente
question déjà vous la recevrez deux mois
en avance par rapport à sa sortie en
librairie c'est beaucoup de mots elle
sera disponible en librairie autour du
24 mars c'est pour ceux qui l'auront
pré-commandé vous la recevrez fin
janvier mais surtout il y a trois packs
de précommandes le premier coûte le même
prix que la BD quand elle sera dans le
commerce c'est-à-dire 15 euros sauf que
vous aurez cette cover exclusive qu'on
ne retrouvera plus jamais sur aucune BD
blig volume 1 après la fin des
précommandes dans 30 jours vous avez
aussi un petit cadeau c'est un stickers
aléatoire parmi 6 stickers qu'on a fait
et aussi évidemment votre nom sera dans
les pages de remerciement à la fin de la
BD il y a ensuite deux autres packs sur
lesquels on s'est éclaté pourquoi parce
qu'on a fait des trucs très RP dans ce
deuxième pack vous aurez donc la BD mais
en plus vous aurez 6 stickers mon
stickers préféré étant celui-ci pour le
moment vous ne savez pas ce que ça
présente mais vous comprendrez faut
peut-être que j'arrête de tenir la BD
c'est c'est trop là vous retrouverez
aussi une lithographie et surtout une
pochette dans laquelle se trouve trois
pièces à conviction liées aux histoires
et vous en apprendrez un peu plus encore
sur l'univers bleak et enfin le dernier
pack le troisième pack celui-là c'est
vraiment pour ceux qui veulent la totale
vous avez dans ce troisième pack tous
les éléments que je viens de citer mais
aussi un coffret collector un t-shirt en
édition limitée une enveloppe qui
contient tous les storyboards les fameux
et mon truc préféré à moi dans ce pack
vous avez une cover exclusive rouge qui
est selon moi absolument magnifique
franchement bref les précommandes sont
donc ouvertes à partir de maintenant et
pour une durée de 30 jours à l'issue
desquels il sera plus possible de se
procurer l'un de ces trois packs mais
par contre pour la faire dataire vous
retrouverez bien entendu en mars la BD
dans son format librairie donc c'est
exactement la même chose sauf que la
cover sera différente je suis ému de
vous annoncer ça c'est pas le seul gros
projet que j'ai cette année il y en a
d'autres qui vont arriver évidemment
mais c'est l'un de mes préférés parce
que ça y est je me lance je sors un truc
d'horreur en dehors des frais d'horreur
donc c'est quand même très simple pour
moi j'espère que les histoires vous
plairont pour ceux qui vont se procurer
la BD j'espère que vous serez fan des
mécaniques j'y tiens [ __ ] on bosse
déjà sur un court-métrage qui sortira
pas loin de la sortie en librairie
justement de la BD en mars et qui promet
qui promet c'est compliqué de faire un
court métrage d'horreur parce que c'est
pas si simple de faire peur via une
vidéo mais honnêtement je pense qu'on a
de très bonnes pistes et surtout on a le
temps de peaufiner le truc là merci à
tous ceux qui précommanderont la BD du
coup ça fait plaisir et puis pour ceux
qui ça n'intéresse pas qui sont pas
sensibles à ça il y a pas de problème
voilà j'ai fini je vous laisse découvrir
le site des précommandes big project.com
on se retrouve dans très peu de temps
pour ce fameux trait d'horreur spécial
cinq histoires qui durera pas loin de 25
minutes quand même donc je pense que
vous devrez être rassasié et puis on se
retrouve pour Halloween pour cette
fameuse grosse vidéo ce gros concept je
suis très curieux de voir votre avis sur
ce concept je pense que vous allez aimer
mais je sais pas dès que je fais un truc
nouveau je suis un peu en stress normal
bah là comme actuellement je lève pas
les bras je les auréoles prenez soin de
vous et on se retrouve bientôt dans de
prochaines vidéos ciao tout le monde
peace j'ai dit ciao tout le monde
naturel ça me fait penser à autre chose
tout le monde peace de l'époque oh
[Musique]